a fiery car crash that killed seven  people in Florida is being investigated  as a possible homicide the wreck  involving two big rigs and two passenger  vehicles happen yesterday on Interstate  75 near Gainesville about 50 gallons of  diesel fuel spilled at the crash site  causing a massive explosion one of the  vehicles was reportedly a van carrying  kids to Disney World anytime that we  have loss of life you know I'm saying  it's tragic unfortunately in this case  we got we had seven people that have  lost their lives the same section of  Interstate was the scene of another  serious accident seven years ago a van  burst into flames during a chain of  collisions in dense fog killing ten  people